a step like that will have its own
really you know devastated effect on
many many many sectors social classes
corporate quite a lot of economic
sectors will be affected by this
movement
however you know i mean this damage is
not going to be only for the clients who
or the card carriers there will be a
damage for the company as well for the
visa and other credit card companies we
are talking about the the sum of 210
million
card holders in russia
and the the greatest statistics show
that around 850 000 cards issued every
month
if you take in consideration how much
the limit or the spend by each
individual
and
of course you're talking about a humble
average of
500 or 600
dollar
who's going to settle this bill if the
company took such a decision it may
[ __ ] a lot of businesses
inside the country and outside the
country because for example it doesn't
mean you know they are only affected as
russian because they import uh product
from outside if they are imported from
europe of course the european suppliers
will be affected and won't be paid their
money in this case so it's not only the
russia will be affected any partner will
be affected as well and if you're
talking about big sectors for example
of course some of the sectors like
energy sectors like gas like petrol
these are
are not included in the in the sanctions
you